good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and today we're going
to be looking at scp-217 object class
Keter special containment procedures
containment area is to be kept behind to
reverse pressure airlocks chemical
shower sterilization full contained
atmosphere hazmat suits and 24-hour post
interaction quarantine and testing are
mandatory for all personnel and during
containment area should containment be
breached the blast door for the
containment and research area will seal
and chemical agent ze ER 217 11 will be
pumped into the air any humans exposed
to scp-217 are to be contained and held
for observation
any items touched by those affected by a
CP 217 must be sterilized description
scp-217 is a virus incurable by current
means with a rate of infectivity at 100%
it affects all organisms in the kingdom
Animalia and can be spread by a touch or
contact with bodily fluid as CP 217 is
very Hardy and can survive for years
outside the host body the progress of
infection is very slow with some
subjects going several years before
manifesting any symptoms scp-217 alters
the biochemistry of organic tissue
causing organic matter to rearrange into
a form of organic metal the process is
involved with this change are not yet
fully understood but the advanced stages
are well documented a subject will begin
to turn into a complex arrangement of
gears and clockwork these taking over
for the former biological functions
advanced stage infection is reported to
be very painful but the earlier stages
are oftentimes unnoticed with only vague
feelings of confusion insomnia and joint
stiffness
hearts are replaced by gears and small
tubes joins by gear networks eyes by
structures not on like primitive hand
crank film cameras etc scp-217 shows
first on the outside of the body in all
creatures except mammals in mammals it
first converts the internal structure
before manifesting outside the body this
can cause those infected to go for very
long periods of time without knowing of
infection scp-217 has even been shown to
totally convert the inside of the body
before showing any externally visible
symptoms scp-217 has infected several
major metropolitan areas in the past
most notably the mental state of those
in middle to advanced stages of
infection has been shown to be much
diminished subjects respond in a
repetitive fashion are very dull and
mechanical in action are easily
distracted and confused and appear
generally irritable when faced with new
problems in addition research on fully
converted brain has been this is
document to 17-6 notes on symptoms
subjects infected by a CP to 17 have at
early stages reported no major symptoms
aside from increased lethargy and a
general lack of emotional response some
have reported a feeling of fluttering or
moving under the skin coupled with a
persistent ticking noise the noise seems
most prominent when scp-217 infects the
shoulders neck and head however it is
audible
if recording equipment is pressed
against an affected area initial
infection of scp-217 is as has been
already stated almost undetectable as
the infection advances subjects begin to
feel a sharp tearing pain in areas that
are being
it has been compared to a knife wound or
a deep muscle tear and can persist for
hours or several things depending on
both the subject and the area affected
the new clockwork organs begin to tear
and rip a tissue for a short time before
becoming fully integrated and settling
into the surrounding tissue and this is
believed to account for the pain areas
infected appear to be metal mainly brass
steel and iron other substances have
been reported appearing to be leather
rubber glass wood and other basic
materials despite appearances it is
purely organic material and even carries
a subjects DNA organs and tissues
affected appear more resilient than
normal carrying the same strength and
density as the materials they resemble
instead of normal tissue density areas
damaged repair overtime but it is much
slower than standard human regeneration
damaged areas can be instantly repaired
by replacing damaged areas with new
parts of the same type testing has shown
that there are no ill effects if parts
made from normal materials replace the
existing biomechanical clockworks
most alarming people infected with
scp-217 can continue for months even
years without being detected with
infections so easy to spread hundreds
could be affected before proper
containment could be enforced infection
appears to spread most quickly in large
offices malls and other large
concentrations of people note anything
or anyone suspected or confirmed to be
infected with scp-217 is not to be
allowed near SCP 882
addendum at this time cross
experimentation between SCP 229 and
scp-217 is allowed only with oh five
approval thank you very much for
listening you are all dismissed thank
you
you